c'est un jeune homme qui s'appelle habig
un conducteur de métro sur la ligne 7 je
ne sais pas si vous avez vu cette
histoire il a été filmée en septembre
dernier par des usagers alors qu'il
donnait un message d'avertissement
contre les pickpockets qui sillonnent
les rames et depuis évidemment il fait
un énorme buzz buzz mérité à mon avis on
a la vidéo regardez je n'évoquais vous
protège et dans les autres grandes
questions 15 face aux aidants montrant
des schémas confiant d'accord on se
protège et un petit peu on change avons
changé le monde change de mains on
sourit à la vie la vie le sourire entre
est bien présente
bonjour je m'appelle la bible je suis
conducteur sera signé set j'ai 37 ans
maman assez surpris dans le car pour moi
je fais rien d'extraordinaire je fais
c'est une annonce pour les voyageurs et
je pense que ce soit dans le train ou en
dehors je pense qu'il faut être un petit
peu un petit peu dans la générosité et
dans la solidarité
la répercussion ça a été que j'ai eu
beaucoup plus de voyageurs qui venaient
me voir pour me féliciter pour nous
remercier mon message un petit peu
bienveillant que j'ai eu à leur égard je
sentis plus d'humanité dans le train
c'est à dire que vraiment les gens
souriaient plus c'était plus contents et
ils s'enfilent meilleure ambiance dans
mon temps
[Applaudissements]
on est très c'est pas forcément de
mauvaise humeur de bonne humeur plutôt
de mauvaise humeur on n'est pas bien et
lui de redonne un petit peu de sourire
surtout en parlant de choses qui sont
des pickpockets des trucs pas su
personnes oui ce qui est génial c'est
qu'en plus dans le métro on le sait tout
sur fois paris tout le monde fait la
gueule sans arrêt tout le monde se
regarde mal assez génial et même lui
maintenant prend du plaisir je sais bien
faire son métier c'est qu'il donne du
sourire les gens lui rendent ce sourire
c'est juste une philosophie de vie
surtout en ce moment
faut que ça continue que ça donne
l'exemple force et vous avez vécu des
choses un peu sympa drôle dans des
transports en commun les uns les autres
oui même dans les avions
bah vous aurez plus les pilotes quand
ils quand on commence à décoller
commence à parler aux gens ils rigolent
les hôtesses etc
ça devient beaucoup plus feelgood et
c'est vraiment agréable mais c'est vrai
que ça donne le sourire s'est mis de
bonne humeur c'est vrai qu'en ce moment
on est tous avec les masques on est tous
un peu angoissé ça détend quand même ça
détend analyse sandrine qu'est ce que
vous en pensez de cette initiative
massa m'a en fait ça m'a fait que je
prenais la ss est justement j'adore ça
qu'on fait des dégâts
et d'un coup le mec pas il fait un
excellent clip officiel et
d'affrontement l'argana sur la garder
tout le monde a envie de dialoguer du
coût de la saga assassin's olalalala
gars soient bien sûr bien évidemment oui
je voulais parler que se faire donc je
voulais juste te dire qu'on est dans une
société de plus en plus individualiste
et ce genre de messages justement c'est
la solidarité entre tous et surtout dans
la période actuelle c'est magnifique on
était encore bravo bravo à lui et
d'ailleurs la jeune femme qui a publié
cette vidéo qui a fait quand même 1,2
million de vues sur twitter en trois
semaines elle a été interviewée au même
horaire et la rente énergétique pas le
même public terre dès que je rentre dans
le métro bassem une bonne humeur tout le
monde applaudit tout le monde rigole je
trouve ça super bienveillant et je me
suis dit bah je partageais ça sur les
réseaux mais j'aurais pas penser à
l'ampleur et bien voilà qu'on a on sait
qu'on s'accroche de gare de l'est
il fait sa petite annonce on va tout le
monde sourire tout le monde rigolait je
monte un peu d'humanisme dans ce petit
monde
dans le métro surtout la lune c'était
super compliqué c'est une des lignes les
plus compliqués donc avoir un chauffeur
qui est bienveillant qui nous
accueillent qui nous parle gentiment
tout un petit mot boubacar talatou dit
elle a tout dit tout ce que vous pouvez
dire à lardy effectivement ça ça
déstresse tout le monde et ça met un peu
de bienveillance dans la rame oui et ça
montre que les réseaux sociaux pour une
fois peuvent aussi faire le buzz sur des
choses positives bien parce que c'est
vrai qu'on en a marre de voir des
violences etc sur les réseaux donc
chapeau c'est à dire du feel good de la
bienveillance on est d'accord bon